so anyways I take Mike Foreman every
morning sometimes I vary it you know I'm
not strict with everything but sometimes
it's half a gram sometimes it's a gram a
typical diabetic will take somewhere
between a gram and two grams so it's bit
below that what else do I do let's get
this all on the table throw it out there
come on right again disclaimer I'm not
recommending is waiting to find out what
you do to make yourself so long
oh well no I don't know if I'm gonna
live longer I'm I'm 50 if you can judge
how am i doing you look fantastic
don't listen to well see to let me know
if I have a gray hair that's been one
thing I guess going all right yeah
anyway okay so let's lay it out so an
nad booster yep how much I take a a gram
of an nad booster every morning and it's
water so you also just take it with a
drink with a coffee along with the
metformin I also take a gram of
resveratrol which isn't a strict amount
I actually just shake some powder into
yogurt and mix it up few spoons of
yogurt I've also been asked over the
internet on Twitter that asked don't you
think that that's breaking the fast it's
no longer fasting like I thought you
said Sinclair yeah well I don't regard
that as as a lot of calories I actually
make my own yogurt it's a it's one made
out of special bacteria are you
considering marketing I bet people buy
if you if you released
well my yogurts it's not mine it's
actually commercially available okay
what where well I don't know the people
who make it so this is not an
endorsement but it's called Bravo and I
know it's in America and Europe okay but
it works out great I don't follow the
instructions I just get full cream milk
I get a jar about that big and I just
pour it all in shake it up put it in the
oven on defrost or whatever it is yes
yeah its body temperature leave it for
about 24 hours and it's beautiful thick
yogurt and for breakfast I take a couple
spoonfuls I'm going to guess I'm
probably not super calorie dense
anyway probably is - full fat yogurt
full fat milk though like yeah how would
you have it maybe a big bowl well I make
it anywhere are left how much you eat 2
spoonfuls 2 or 3 it's not not breaking
the fast I think they say if you
breaking the fast Christie thank you
they may leave the room don't worry um
so what else you do whilst you do your
exercising your fasting you have your
NID got your resveratrol you've got your
map form right is that that's the main
thing I mean um my doctor gives gives me
a statin because I've had high
cholesterol since I was in my 20s so
that's another you know thanks Jewish
genes I'm kind of screwed there um I
take a still take a baby aspirin a day
even though that a baby aspirin well
it's it's anyone milligrams of aspirin
okay what's that for blood thinning
right right and the current
recommendation in general from the
Medical Association just so it clear I'm
not a doctor but I read the literature
is that if you haven't had a heart
attack
maybe maybe not take it I haven't had a
heart attack yet but I'm I'm convinced
that it will help with my blood flow
gosh I hope not that would be a bad look
that would be a really bad luck wouldn't
it yeah
[Music]
you